would anyone else run against Donald
Trump it's very tough right now I mean
there are other people running there's
this guy Vivek ramaswamy who's running
uh Nikki Haley is running her campaign
basically Dead on Arrival Trump actually
does better in polls the more people run
when when it's just him and DeSantis
that's the best scenario for DeSantis
it's not great for DeSantis but it's
it's uh certainly better
um but I think the difficulty is this is
a question for Republicans to figure out
the people who rightly recognized in
2016 that this guy is not good for their
party
um still believe this guy's not good for
their party but many of them recognize
that most of the voters are still behind
him
you can always say it's early his
polling doesn't really mean anything
anything could happen something major
would have to happen for Trump to lose
that lead if he got more uh if he was
arrested two more times and had more
indictments and it just became like this
guy can't even campaign because he's so
busy going from court to court maybe
that would make a difference